Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David, if you have something
to say to me. You can say it to my voicemail
line, even if it's 3 a.m. when you get the idea.
Here is the eggman. He is not buying my entire
I'm Argentinean thing, at least not in terms of me
just being a white guy. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hi, Dave.
I know you're Argentinian and you
guys won the FIFA thing. You know,
whatever. Right. Congratulations to you.
Speaker 1: The egg man is not big on sports,
and he will admit that to you.
Speaker 2: David, you're a New
York white guy. Okay. I'm going to have
to agree with Donald Trump over you. Well,
in the pronunciation of his sock drawer,
a soccer freaking sock drawer. Okay. You
put your socks in the drawer and
you close it. What's the problem,
shallow brother? Sock drawer. You are?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Listen, I didn't grow up in
New York, so I have not adopted any of these New
York accent elements. I believe that my accent is
what's called the southern western New England
accent. And sock drawer doesn't make any sense
to me. It's. It's a sock drawer. It's a drawer.
It's a a number of drawers. Many drawers drawer.
It doesn't make any sense. But in any case, the
story Trump told about the sock drawer was very
much untrue. Okay. On the bonus show today, what
the hell happened with the FAA and all flights
being temporarily grounded and how much Blame the
Secretary of Transportation, Pete Boutte Edge.
Edge would've judge how much blamed as Secretary
Pete deserve. Fox News thinks it's a lot and we'll
talk about it. The Biden administration is going
to be selecting the first ten drugs for which it
will negotiate prices within the Medicare program
by September. What drugs might those be? We will
discuss. And what will the impact on pricing
be? We will also talk about that. And lastly,
House Republicans, they want people back to work.
They want everybody back in the office. House
Republicans are introducing a bill to return all
federal employees to the office. I have a number
of friends who are federal employees and they are
thrilled. And I understand why many of their jobs
really don't need to be done in an office,
quite frankly. We will talk about it on the
bonus show when producer Pat joins me from sunny
Florida. You can get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at join Packman dot com.
Speaker 2: O the bonus show where you want
to make money please somebody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, I don't know about that,
but you can sign up at join Packman dot com and
you can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
save big you get 100% of the benefits but at
half the price. Hard to beat that.
I will see you on the bonus show.